ça faisait longtemps les choses ont
changé j'entends depuis peu des rumeurs
concernant le retour de ce roman en tant
qu'héritier de l'Empire
nous devons nous préparer au pire
Jedi sont tombés il y a longtemps il
n'en reste qu'une poignée
[Musique]
quelque chose approche
quelque chose de sombre
[Musique]
je le sens
c'est un nouveau départ
pour certains
la guerre
pour d'autres
le pouvoir
[Musique]
ça faisait longtemps
les choses ont changé
j'entends depuis peu des rumeurs
concernant le retour de trône
en tant qu'héritier de l'Empire
[Musique]
nous devons nous préparer au pire
sans tomber il y a longtemps
il n'en reste qu'une poignée
[Musique]
l'heure est peut-être venue de tout
recommencer